puertas clausuradas y silencio en las
calles las escuelas y los negocios de
haití cerraron el lunes mientras el país
conmemoraba un sombrío aniversario han
pasado siete meses desde el asesinato
del presidente joven al morir y haití
parece estar lejos de una transición
política el primer ministro ariel hoy y
renovó su llamado a organizar elecciones
prometiendo la creación de un consejo
electoral provisional una la elección
son necesarias varias condiciones para
organizar las elecciones realizar
consultas públicas y adoptar una nueva
constitución en primer lugar hay que
hacer frente a la inseguridad además del
aniversario de la muerte de maurice el
lunes marcaría también el fin del
periodo presidencial de cinco años del
fallecido presidente los opositores a
hoy argumentan que su administración es
por tanto inconstitucional y exigen que
renuncie para dar paso a un gobierno de
transición
esta noche marca el fin del periodo de
este primer ministro de facto y del
servicio que ha ofrecido al pueblo su
deber ahora es ocuparse sólo de los
asuntos rutinarios
la nación caribeña adif un repunte en la
violencia de las pandillas y una
creciente incertidumbre desde el
asesinato del presidente aquí sólo
cuenta con 10 cargos electos después de
que no celebrará elecciones legislativas
en 2019 en medio de la paralización
política de las protestas varios grupos
políticos desafían a hoy y han nombrado
a sus propios líderes pero el primer
ministro se niega a reconocerlos